why welcome to this video playing Yemm
daddy no name ok and she get to that
symmetrical English they all play this
t6 stuff ok maybe they want to hear they
want to get into this hmm I wonder if
this is actually a precise water for
white will team
let's go 85 I he might he can take with
the bishop now now that wasn't a good
move but ok now know everything is good
check what he just played was also a bit
bit off I think and light no it's a
pretty pretty miss place down ok so now
we're here and now take take a true gay
one I guess maybe I'm not sure if I
should take to be honest c4 is hanging
so check one thing I do know is he wants
to have like four minutes on the clock
at the end so kd5 not sure how much of
an issue that is looks a bit strange but
what is his what is he doing with the d5
pawn him cannot easily move the Queen
away then I take it yeah this this stuff
here of course
yeah you for is also an option here but
doesn't quite work threatening lucrative
seven now
just winning d5 okay so look g7 group t7
Queenie six rook f7 has a funny way to
win the game well maybe maybe allows
that I mean you can try for those things
okay well here King takes isn't that
clear but I can definitely take so takes
King takes 55 check kf8 unfortunately
not all that great
and 55 is a bit lame
don't want them to play rupee idea
absolutely not maybe I should just move
this we are so going to e7 to be honest
because this doesn't interfere with
anything don't want to trade all that
much with my rookie singing this is what
I meant look at seven very likely would
have been better
maybe Bishop g6 is a move that you can
play out on your future take bishop g6
is the thing kinky five maybe and Bishop
doesn't have a good square right only
hook the aid and rook t7 takes time
morning no time Kim so the next king e4
and Bishop f4 is played maybe you can
play a three year and total irritate me
okay Bishop Bishop f4 though
tic tactics tactics tactics draw our
third okay time guys I probably have to
it's a bit of a shame run are drawn yeah
cause I should win this someone like
this aunty resigned sort yeah that's
just so good where do i go back actually
hey SS must be winning air force i mean
this is this is not a big question the
position was winning for quite a long
time because you weakened himself as
much as possible this thing's yeah route
t7 I probably should just take and this
and then then it's already gone I was 22
tempted by by this little trick that he
cannot go here because I will get seven
right okay who gave six this is just a
crab position for black still it's got
many weaknesses and there's no
compensation for it okay I should have
taken here first this is also good you
know what the engines are given here
giving me this pawn it getting getting
this in check yeah went around Tok the
only thing is hey I maybe I just must
must play the simple moves and win and I
don't King see six wins easily I wanted
to wanted to go to the f porn just to
make sure everything's simple and stuff
but this is just saving him because he
can always check stake here and
I instead again just go go here it's
just over I don't know what it's really
unnecessarily nervous well I'm
unnecessarily nervous there with one
minute and one minute is still plenty of
time so i don't know i don't know just a
little bit off in the mood ok guys
thanks for watching